[Musique]
c'est le scandale qui en ce début
d'année a défrayé la chronique
l'altercation entre des candidats des
anges de la télé réalité alors en
tournage à la réunion et du riz bédié le
maire de saint-andré une affaire qui
avait fait beaucoup de bruit
nous avions reçu des témoignages
plaidant pour chacun des partis ricardo
et neruda les deux candidats mise en
cause on y est plus tard être à
l'origine de ce conflit
mettez vous à ma place vous êtes la
victime du truc et cerveau qu'on fait
porter le chapeau
les équipes du programme sont
aujourd'hui en train de travailler pour
relancer le tournage
sauf que les internautes se demandent si
après ce dérapage le couple fera partie
ou non de l' aventure si rien n'est
officiel sur instagram neruda a publié
une photo le vent le doute vous fait
encore partie du casting des vacances
des anges faut qu'on nous fait croire
que peut-être mais normalement c'est
mort pour certains fans tant qu'on ne
connaît pas la vérité sur l' affaire il
n'y a pas de raison de les empêcher de
tourner alors ricardo et neruda
doivent-ils être autorisé à paraître
dans la prochaine saison des anges nous
vous dévoilons toutes les nouvelles
infos en plateau et oui on les dévoile
en plateau ses nouvelles
rires oui oui monsieur alors qu alors
assez pauvre ricardo et neruda ils ne
seront pas sur la saison des anges ils
ont été exclus du casting
il faut savoir que la production les
soutiens parce que c'est vrai qu'on l'a
dit dans cette affaire on sait pas
vraiment ce qui s'est passé on sait pas
qui a tapé le premier est ce que c'est
le maire est ce que c'est ricardo et
noda mais la chaîne en fait ne cautionne
pas du tout toute image de violence
autour du programme que ce soit de leur
faute ou pas de leur faute
donc ils sont obligés de les exclure du
programme ils ne feront pas partie de
cette saison des anges
l'autre info que j'ai c'est que le
tournage il aura lieu c'est en
république dominicaine et tout ça c'est
pour des raisons financières je vais
préparer un petit tableau et toutes les
infos par tous alors qu'un épisode les
vacances des anges les vacances d angers
pas les anges s'est vendu 60 mille euros
d'accord il a 60 épisodes 3 millions 6
du chiffre d'affaires
ce genre d'émission sa marge à 30%
environ un million cent euros de marque
un million cent pour le producteur pour
le producteur marc chagall c'est
préserver leurs marges à tout prix parce
qu'on l'a dit ils ont perdu environ
juste des pertes allant jusqu'à 500
mille euros avec tout cet incident est
en fait maintenant le producteur des ans
et le producteur de la vina des coeurs
brisés aussi accord pour régulièrement
république dominicaine dont pour limiter
la casse
il a déjà ses contacts là bas il a déjà
ses prix il a déjà ses filles ce qu'on
appelle des financeurs qui tournerait
ans répondait oui c'est sûr dans
quelques jours aurait plus dominicaine
diffusion prévue fin mars début avril
d'accord très bien oui alors j'ai eu
vous savez mon pti blogueurs mais caf
langues de vip
d'accord il s'occupe justement des
candidats de télé réalité on a échangé
des petits messages et il m'a dit que
visiblement donc la prod voulait les
garder parce que c'était vraiment le
les personnages phares de ce casting et
qui sont vraiment très déçu de ne pas
les avoir que c'est vraiment la chaîne
qui a dit non et ricardo est très très
très déçu parce que maintenant ils se
retrouvent tous les deux le bec dans
l'eau parce qu'ils ont dit non à 2
émission de w9 à savoir les apprentis
aventuriers et le creusot vous savez les
marseillais versus donc les pauvres se
retrouve sans rien il se retrouve sans
rien et donc maintenant ils sont très
déçus et l'enquêté toujours en cours et
visiblement ils sauront d'ici deux ou
trois ans le résultat s'ils sont
capables ou non de travail à faire bon
alors on se rabat longtemps oui moi je
trouve qu'ils ont un job de rêve et ils
doivent respecter leur image et s'ils
sont diffusés c'est parce qu'ils ont une
image donc ils doivent la respecter
moi dernièrement je me suis embrouillé
avec quelqu'un de la sncf une
contrôleuse non et c'est parti même très
loin et je veux dire c'est que cette
histoire à rêver à une bagarre
il faut que les deux y ait donc je suis
désolé ils sont responsables de rien
avec une contrôleuse rsa c'est pourquoi
donc mais à cause de la cause d'un titre
de transport
vous étiez vous le dire je veux dire
j'ai monté très très haut niveau volume
sonore mais pour en arriver aux mains
c'est que ils ont tort aussi eh oui ils
ont une image doit faire attention
il a été diffusé c'est ainsi qu'ils sont
victimes
bien sûr pas si son but il faut voir
mais mont asama moi moi j'ai été les
premiers à taper dessus pour le premier
or quand on nous a dit oui ils sont
bagarrés jeudi li ces photos il faut
qu'ils se laissent pas en photo là je
suis pas content et honte à la
production si les ont viré c'est si les
ont viré c'est qu'ils sont coupables
sinon ils virent pas nécessaire et si
c'est la chaîne de la chaîne énergie la
raison la production répond pas palerme
et la production a c'est très bien si
l'on fait quelque chose ou pas oui mais
je donne un exemple pour pas diffuser
non par un jour et je mens je
m'embrouille avec quelqu'un tu sais que
j'ai rien fait tu vas me dire et du
famille du programme pays
jean va pas me virer du programme si tu
sais que j'ai rien fait tu vas me
laisser sécher rexona je file un
programme comme on l'expliqué tu vas
dire moi en tant que producteur tu vas
appelé la chaîne tu veux redire il a
rien fait l'enquêté ne mènera à rien
c'est pas lui il s'est fait agresser il
n'a rien fait vous me verrez pas du
programme fait c'est la bonne question
si la production défend par les mecs
c'est qu'ils ont fait quelque chose mais
cyril origine la vérité c'est qu'on sait
pas ce qui s'est passé on sait pas s'ils
sont coupables à londres a dit la
vieille éthique bas niveau depuis mai
bien voir chaîne de télé aujourd'hui
c'est quand ya un incident avant de
savoir s'ils sont coupables moubarak et
les gens de l'antenne mais non là oui je
redis non moi je voudrais parler parce
que j'ai pris aussi la parole là dessus
et j'essaie pas manquer moi je pense que
d'abord il y avait six avaient une
pétition qui avait demandé s'il allait
participer au programme des anges y
aurait une pétition pour dire mme allard
surtout pas qu'ils participent donc
toute façon je pense que la solution
était inextricable je pense qu'ils ont
été victimes
et d'ailleurs à quelque chose auquel
j'ai participé ça ne sorte d'emballement
médiatique où finalement on a jugé des
images sans savoir
on a six mois j'ai carrément je les ai
accusé tout ça parce qu'il y avait eu un
quasi avant donc le casier avant n'est
pas le casier aujourd'hui est donc
effectivement ils sont victimes de ce
truc là et aujourd'hui c'est
inextricable pour la chaîne il a
conseillé les spectateurs à 73% à 27 %
contre 73 %
les gens sont d'accord sur la réduction